bonsoir à trois jours du référendum pour
mas reach l'europe monétaire est en
crise la livre et la lyre décroche
première victime politique le
britannique john majeure non soir
première journée de convalescence à
l'elysée pour françois mitterrand la
chancellerie hausse le ton dans le
conflit des prisons les sanctions seront
appliquées
enfin l'arrestation d'un parrain de la
mafia marseille et interviews exclusives
dans ce journal du dernier survivant du
pool anti mafia giuseppe ayala le
serpent est en lambeaux le système
monétaire européen vient de connaître sa
plus sérieuses secousses depuis sa
création en 1979 le premier coup de vent
la semaine dernière a donc été suivi par
une véritable tempête une europe qui
attend le résultat du référendum en
france
un attentisme qui a ramené les places
financières au calme ce matin la bourse
de paris a clôturé à -0 38%
mais cette crise spéculative sans
précédent a touché de plein fouet
londres rome et à une moindre mesure
madrid claude guaino la livre a quitté
le système monétaire européen elle
flotte ce qui veut dire qu'elle est de
fait d'évaluer à paris par exemple elle
est tombé de 9 francs 47e' hier à 9
francs 0 3 aujourd'hui
avez vous perdu le contrôle de
l'économie demande ton premier ministre
britannique
en fait pour la livre c'est
l'aboutissement d'une crise de confiance
la grande bretagne est en récession
depuis trois ans et sa monnaie a fini
par faire les frais du marasme
économique
techniquement dans le système monétaire
européen la valeur d'une monnaie est
fixé par rapport aux autres
la valeur plancher du franc par exemple
est de 3 francs 42 pour un marc la livre
elle ne devait pas descendre en dessous
de deux marques 77 hier pour les
spéculateurs
pour plusieurs raisons ils se sont
acharnés contre la livre ils en ont
vendu des milliards contre du marque
pour les contrer les banques centrales
ont racheté ses livres dont personne ne
voulait objectif la maintenir au dessus
de la barre des 2 marques 77 à la fin de
la journée la banque d'angleterre était
obligé de capituler devant la
spéculation à bruxelles cette nuit le
communiqué monétaire européens
acceptaient de laisser la libre
sortir du sms de même que la lire
italienne l'un peu c'est a été dévalué
quant au franc il résiste mais
s'affaiblit face aux marques consorts
restant suspendu au résultat du
référendum de dimanche à londres la
crise monétaire tourne à la crise
politique du jeune majeur le premier
ministre est dans une position très
inconfortable
son ministre des finances a dû faire
marche arrière et dès ce matin le
gouvernement s'est réuni en urgence
autour du premier ministre
autre preuve de l'importance de la crise
le parlement pourrait être convoqué en
session extraordinaire dès la semaine
prochaine alors analyse donc maintenant
après ce coup de torchon monétaire les
explications de jean marc sylvestre à la
bourse de paris
le retour au calme et relativement
précaires et les milieux d'affaires ont
bien le sentiment de vivre la lune
accalmie toute provisoire sujet
d'inquiétude très grave au niveau
économique bien sûr compte tenu de la
difficulté qu auront un certain nombre
de pays l'angleterre l'italie et
l'espagne de se mettre à niveau du
fonctionnement du système monétaire
européen inquiétudes politiques graves
aussi portant sur les incertitudes du
référendum de maastricht il est bien
évident que si le non l'emportait à ce
référendum la majorité des milieux
d'affaires considèrent que le système
monétaire européen pourrait exploser
qu'il en serait fini de la perspective
de la monnaie unique que cela remettrait
en cause les chances ou les perspectives
d'une relance économique concertée au
niveau de l'europe relance sur
l'investissement relance sur l'emploi
dès ce matin pierre bérégovoy allier la
situation monétaire européenne au
résultat du référendum de dimanche pour
le premier ministre un oui france à
d'immenses stabiliserait à nouveau les
marchés
c'est une interview exclusive france 3
recueilli ce matin par nos confrères de
reims pierre bérégovoy tel monétaire
européen lui est atteint il est atteint
sous l'effet de deux phénomènes
le premier c'est la situation
économique difficile de la
grande-bretagne et la situation
économique et financière difficile de
l'italie ça joue contre ces deux
monnaies deuxième cause des difficultés
actuelles le nom d'anne warm et ils ont
le suspense qui demeurent sur les
résultats du référendum en france
cl oui ils l'emportent ça ira mieux
si le nom devait l'emporter nous aurions
interface pas seulement les français
mais les autres pays européens à des
difficultés françois mitterrand ira bien
voté dimanche à satoshi nom avant cela
le chef de l'état n'a qu'un mot inscrit
à son agenda convalescence il n'a fait
qu'une courte apparition dans les
bureaux de l'elysée aujourd'hui il se
repose dans ses appartements et la santé
les chefs d'état et la transparence est
un domaine où les états unis sont
souvent cité en exemple un pays où la
presse a une longue tradition dans kate
et d'investigation en france le
comportement de françois mitterrand est
véritablement nouveau et les nombreux
journalistes présents à paris pour le
référendum
on notait changement ils l'ont saluée
aussi sur l françois du mans il s'agit
bien d'un cancer de la prostate
à défaut de première médicale dans le
sens follano du cancer du président
constitue néanmoins une première
médiatique en france
le candidat françois-mitterand 80
s'était engagé à rendre au public deux
fois par an son état de santé
une tradition que américaine
pour les américaines ça existe et il est
pas par exemple avec président roosevelt
pendant la conférence et yonne
il était malade et maintenant les
historiennes indique son maladie se
toucher là qu'en france parce qu'il
n'était pas très pour reprendre les
négociations mais des pluies
le président américain le problème
maladie étaient exposés tous les
locataires de la maison blanche ont
suivi l'exemple ce fut le cas d'aï
weiwei victime d'une crise cardiaque
2 kennedy du reggane et enfin de george
bush
c'est toujours comme ça aux états unis
et moi et moi j'ai tous ces bons depuis
des années j'ai trouvé je trouvais que
la mairie en français chantent ont
changé beaucoup beaucoup de changements
et c'est plutôt vers le système
américaine et je crois que ça c'est
aussi un indice que peut-être pas de
marque notation mais c'est peut-être
tout est organisation si l'on respecte
les traditions en amérique en france on
tient ses promesses la démocratie
moderne selon l'oit aujourd'hui de cette
transparence vécu comme une nécessité
mas reach portraits de campagne pour un
référendum mais ce soir les verts des
verts qui ont réussi la performance de
tenir des meetings avec côte à côte à la
tribune des partisans du oui et du non
antoine vestaires lui s'est
personnellement engagé dans le camp du
oui assez discrètement tout de même il
ne tiendra qu'à un meeting ce soir à
strasbourg mais a meeting assez
médiatique puisqu'il sera aux côtés de
ségolène royal les verts en campagne le
reportage est signé véronique aurel et
pierre michel elle dominique voynet
défendre le nom lui yves cochet plaide
pour le oui à la politique autrement
d'accord tout le temps là vu le oui et
le non à maastricht côte à côte pour un
débat contradictoire à quatre jours du
scrutin
une situation qui n'a pas l'air de
troubler les militants le fait de
laisser ainsi la responsabilité
en dernier ressort à chaque électeur
ça au nord tout à fait
les faire si ça favorise de l'urgence
d'un débat de fond sur l'europe ça peut
être positif malgré le oui combative
d'antoine waechter l'hiver n'en fut
dégagée de réponse commune pour le
référendum
du coup chacun défend son point de vue
l'eba contradictoires sans confrontation
dominique voynet yves cochet sont
d'accord sur l'essentiel ils sont
européens
ils déplorent tous les deux les
insuffisances du traité alors alors ce
sont d'autres considérations qui les
motive
je connais mal les gens du nom donc si
je dis oui à l'europe
c'est pas parce que c'est celle que je
souhaite mais c'est parce que je dis non
à faible je redoute
nous savons que le oui des uns n'est pas
une résignation à l'europe libérale que
le nom des autres n'est pas une
résignation à une europe nationaliste
est construite les nations se l'était
pas donc je crois que c'est ça qui est
important et je crois que ça peut
augmenter la cohésion des verts partagés
sur les réponses à donner le 20
septembre les verts préparent déjà
l'après référendum
en espérant que l'europe ne laissera pas
trop de cicatrices dans leur mouvement
le conflit des prisons et la
chancellerie hausse le ton les sanctions
seront appliquées en tout 90 mises à
pied ont été prononcées à l'encontre du
gardien de grévistes côté négociations
là encore le garde des sceaux change de
stratégie
oui michel vauzelle propose maintenant
des discussions directement sur le
terrain avec la mise en place de
commission dirigée par des préfets
les syndicats de leur côté ont déjà
refusé commentaire de clément weill
raynal
fleury mérogis cet après midi la
majorité des surveillants est toujours
en grève
à l'intérieur de la prison de service
est assuré par les gardes mobiles de la
gendarmerie
mais l'établissement tourne au ralenti
peu une pas de promenade pour les
détenus incertitude pour les familles de
pouvoir se rendre au parloir
on va vous donner la liste des
établissements qui sont en grève ou en
vous voir très dur j'ai à la sent ici à
fleury on semble décidé à ne pas
abandonner le mouvement malgré la
confirmation des sanctions annoncées
aujourd'hui par la chancellerie
reste qu'il est difficile ce soir
d'apprécier l'exacte étendue de la
mobilisation 99 prisons touchées selon
le ministère
140 selon les syndicats le bras de fer
continue entre les gardiens de prison et
le ministère de la justice visiblement
la chancellerie a décidé de jouer
l'essoufflement du mouvement dès demain
de nouvelles négociations vont s'entamer
mais au plan local cette fois chaque
préfet a reçu pour mission de régler les
problèmes de sécurité spécifiques à
chaque prison alors le deck active à
aller travailler
un traitement du conflit au niveau
départemental cette initiative de la
chancellerie viserait à court circuiter
les syndicats nationaux accusé de
vouloir jouer la surenchère dans le
conflit ce soir les principaux syndicats
ufap en tête ont d'ailleurs refusé toute
négociation au niveau régional et puis
depuis 48 heures la prison de clairvaux
dans l'aube et fouillé de fond en comble
les évadés de la semaine dernière vers
réussi on sait à dissimuler une arme et
les gardiens leur côté avaient obtenu le
principe de cette évacuation en règle
reportage france 3 races
un ancien détenu photographiée larmes
aux points devant le mur du centre de
détention de clairvaux ce document
publié ce matin par paris match est
passé entre toutes les mains des
surveillants exagéré truqués le vrai ou
faux les commentaires divergent mais
tous sont d'accord sur un point la
sécurité à clairvaux n'est pas fiable à
100 % on n'aura jamais une sécurité
fiable à 100% à partir de l'instant où
des détenus ont le droit de n'effectuer
les commandes extérieures des livraisons
que l'on approvisionne des ateliers
qu'ils ont un contact avec les personnes
extérieures de l'administration
pénitentiaire tout est possible à
commencer par la complicité d'un détenu
affecté à l'entretien des espaces verts
et autorisé à circuler dans toute la
détention une arme dissimulée dans la
chaussette peut très bien franchir un
portique électronique sans être détecté
à moins de 70 centimètres du sol la cour
de promenade n'excède pas 4 mètres de
haut il n'y a pas de grillage et aucune
barrière anti franchissement réclamé par
les surveillants
un dispositif de sécurité à revoir
entièrement ce matin pourtant gendarmes
et gardes mobiles ont commencé la
fouille
la partie centrale passé au peigne fin
les cellules ausculté halal ou le tout
suivi de quelques conseils donnés aux
enquêteurs du srpj de reims par certains
surveillants
nous avons dit aux enquêteurs qu'il ne
fallait surtout pas qu'ils oublient dû
démonter les cuvettes de wc dans les
cellules car apparemment ça n'avait pas
été fait et sous une cuvette de wc on
peut cacher un 357 magnum très
facilement un conseil en forme d'aveu
des hommes ont donc effectivement
franchi l'enceinte de la prison
juges et inviolable il ya seulement
quelques jours
rebondissement dans la sphère de la
société générale et cette fois c'est le
promoteur immobilier christian pellerin
qui se retrouve inculpé de délit
d'initié il est soupçonné d'avoir
spéculé sur des actions société générale
avant que le raid ne soit rendue
publique
christian pellerin qui avait déjà été
inculpée dans la sphère de la tour bp le
point sur cette affaire justement avec
nathalie darrigrand christian pellerin
l'un des plus importants promoteurs
immobiliers français
son nom était jusqu'ici liés au scandale
du rachat de la tourbe au pea la défense
affaire dans laquelle il reste inculpé
deux complices
et d'abus de biens sociaux aujourd'hui
le voici sous le coup du deuxième
inculpation dans une autre affaire celle
du raid manqué sur la société générale
en septembre et octobre 88
il a été inculpé cet après-midi de délit
d'initié la commission des opérations de
bourse lui reproche d'avoir acheté des
titres de la société générale avant que
l'offre publique d'achat soit annoncée
montant de la plus-value 3 millions de
francs six personnes ont déjà été
inculpées depuis le début de l' affaire
dont l'ancien directeur de cabinet de
pierre bérégovoy alors ministre des
finances jean charles naouri ainsi que
le financier libanais samir traboulsi
pour l'instant christian pellerin s'est
refusé à toute déclaration
un procès pour la mémoire et pour
l'exemple des familles de victimes d'un
accident d'avion demande une
indemnisation substantielle et cette
affaire pourrait bien faire
jurisprudence pour les compagnies
aériennes en effet le dossier
d'importance jusqu alors les
indemnisations ont été plafonnées en cas
d'accident
si le 29 octobre le jugement prend en
compte une faute grave de l'équipage il
en sera tout autrement
les explications de jean-françois
bélanger faire
est mort pour rien et ça c'est pas ce
n'est pas normal est les sommes qui nous
ont été proposés ont été de 20 mille
francs par frère parfait et 50 francs
par tarn marie bos a perdu son frère
pierre lors du crash de l'avion d'air
littoral en décembre 87 à bordeaux
treize passagers prenaient place à bord
du bimoteur brasilia affrété par air
france une rentrée de bruxelles pour
passer leurs vacances de noël
a bordeaux ils ne verront plus la
garonne l'avion s'écrase avant
l'atterrissage l'anc est conclu à la
responsabilité des pilotes tous deux
morts dans l'accident
enfin des procédures pénales cinq ans
après les familles des victimes n'ont
toujours pas été indemnisés
les sommes proposées par les compagnies
d'assurances ne sont pas jugées
suffisantes plus que dédommagement les
familles veulent qu'une punition
un exemple avion coûte cher arrières
littoral les passagers ne coûte rien le
jour où les passagers coûteront cher
peut-être que de plus grandes
précautions pourront être prises en
somme les familles demandent une
indemnité proportionnelle à la gravité
des fautes commises par les pilotes et
les compagnies aériennes
pas question répond les transporteurs
qui préfèrent s'en tenir à la
jurisprudence actuelle l'importance de
la faute commise n'a aucune incidence
sur le montant des dommages et intérêts
alloués les montrent les dommages et
intérêts sont alloués en fonction exacte
de l'importante du préjudice
si elle était acceptée l'argumentation
des familles des victimes créerait un
précédent en france une brèche ouverte
vers une escalade des dommages et
intérêts comme aux états unis
c'est ce que veulent à tout prix éviter
les compagnies aériennes un parrain de
la mafia calabraise arrêté à marseille
c'était en fait installé discrètement
dans la ville il ya déjà deux ans il
était surveillé par les policiers depuis
plusieurs mois et il a été placé ce soir
en garde à sept arrestations le prouvent
l'européanisation la mafia n'est pas un
fait nouveau loin de là c'est la raison
pour laquelle les ministres de la
justice et de l'intérieur des 12 ont
décidé de coordonner leurs efforts une
grande réunion aura lieu demain à
bruxelles c'est une grande première sur
ce dossier le témoignage le plus rare
est sûrement le plus intéressant est
celui du dernier survivant du pool anti
mafia giuseppe ayala il a quitté la
magistrature pour la politique mais
c'est pour mieux lutter contre cosa
nostra
c'est une interview exclu
yves recueillis à rome partir
friedenreich et ils vont de leur fils
même leurs vacances il les passait
ensemble 3 sicilien trois magistrats un
inséparable trio à eux seuls à eux trois
ils formaient le pool anti mafia ii sont
morts assassinés
falcone et borsellino reste aujourd'hui
giuseppe raya la seule personne à
convaincre quand même bonnes soldes et
notamment à côté de falcone et
borsellino je suis un toupet mais aussi
petit que je sois je ne reculerai
certainement pas je me dois d'honorer la
mémoire de mes amis depuis leur
assassinat s'opère un changement en
italie un pays qui ne fait plus de
politique quand il est corrompu et c'est
pour cela que si ces tueries certains
mobiliser l'opinion publique à pousser
encore plus fort aller dans le sens
d'une italie différentes est meilleur
alors ce sera notre manière à nous de
prouver que falcone et borsellino ne
sont pas morts inutilement l' isolement
et son armure
il vit seul loin de sa famille et a rayé
de sa vie les imprévus parmi les
dossiers que le pool anti-mafia
peaufinait se trouve un chapitre qui n'a
cessé de grossir les ramifications de
cosa nostra dans l'europe communautaire
l'intérim était mafia comment et où la
mafia s'exporte hôtel au delà de la
sicile et de l'italie ce talent là où
des marchés intéressants garantissent
d'importants profits
la france est le pays idéal les marchés
existent la france est donc une cible de
choix pour la mafia un pays très
attractif
l'europe unie qui démarre en 93 ne
posera strictement aucun problème à la
mafia même si ce n'est pas forcément
pour elle une situation avantageuse
en fait la mafia déplace ses capitaux et
ses intérêts sans aucune difficulté au
delà de nos frontières et elle le fait
déjà depuis pas mal de temps
elle possède des réseaux très à filtrer
des méthodes de pénétration très au
point
ce qui fait elle n'a absolument pas
besoin qu officiellement
les frontières puisque pourrait que ces
frontières sont tombés il ya déjà pas
mal d'années clandestinement bien
évidemment depuis peu il a laissé de
côté la magistrature persuadé que le
meilleur endroit pour combattre la mafia
n'est plus au palais de justice mais
bien dans les allées du pouvoir romain
au coeur du trastevere à rome
sa maison est surveillé jour et nuit
giuseppe ayala occupe une place de choix
sur la liste noire de cosa nostra
elle a un vieux compte à régler avec
luis ayala lors du maxi procès de
palerme en 1987 a requis contre les 300
mafiosi 2000 ans de prison de quoi se
faire quelques ennemis football bon
début de coupe d'europe pour les clubs
français quatre victoires et un match
nul pour auxerre alain dorgans nous
présente maintenant une sélection des
plus beaux buts de cette première
journée européenne
le milan ac son conglomérat
d'individualités n'ont pas eu à forcer
leur talent devant les slovènes de
ljubljana van basten en deux temps
s'ouvre le chemin des filets le plus
beau but milanais c'est celui ci une
pure merveille de gestes techniques seul
auteur dimitriou albertini le tandem
gullit van basten fonctionne bien ce
centre au cordeau de ruud gullit est
repris par van basten et jean pierre
papin restera t'il eu et jpp a eu aussi
son but servi sur un plateau par gullit
4-0 la coupe est pleine le milan ac
jouera le prochain tour du championnat
d'europe des clubs c'est une quasi
certitude
l'autre grand du football italien la
juventus de turin a eu aussi la main
lourde face au chypriote de famagouste
ossibadjouo ouvre la marque
le dynamiteur tuerie noah sera gianluca
vialli qui inscrit son premier but suite
à un excellent travail préparatoire de
badges son deuxième but gianluca vialli
il doit la tribu à son opportunisme
esseulé devant les buts il ne laisse
aucune chance au gardien chypriote kipré
victoire témoigne de la vitalité de la
supériorité du football italien
bercy salle comble on devrait dire
évidemment puisque bercy est investie
depuis deux jours par johnny et ses
milliers de fans c'est le concert de
l'automne à paris et johnny s'avoue ravi
de retrouver la scène il l'a confié à
michel vial et philippe guinet avant de
donner son son et c'est reparti pour
johnny une nouvelle fois la troisième au
palais omnisports de paris bercy pour
son traditionnel rendez vous avec le
public
trois générations de fans qui ne
manqueraient pour rien au monde
trois générations assemblée pour un show
qui va justement résumé 33 ans de
carrière comme une sorte d'épopée
artistique
radieux la vie
merci ça implique le match en mains
sales j'ai pris l'habitude de faire
merci tous les deux ans
commence comme ça que moi j'aime
beaucoup parce que elle est grande sa
donne la possibilité de faire des choses
qu'on a envie de faire un petit peu à la
démesure de deux de nos envies et de
noël et c'est vrai je me suis pas
surpris être mort le frac donc enfin la
scène c'est votre univers
on sent que vous visiez petit vous y est
bien parce que c'est l'endroit où je me
sens le mieux parce que nous sommes chez
points c'est pas très intimes mais je
suis un peu sûres
non
la jeunesse est au fond aujourd'hui vous
n'avez plus rien à prouver
non mais je m'amuse je m'amuse
bonjour
à quel âge
des images maintenant étonnant de
grenouilles dans l'espace et c'est
l'équipage de la navette américaine qui
emportait donc avec lui toute une petite
colonie et la grande nouvelle c'est
qu'un heureux événement a eu lieu en
plein coeur de l'espace des petits
têtards sonné à bord dans des aveux et
l'événement devait se devait d'être
célébré nicole bappel la navette
endeavour va-t-elle devenir le berceau
de la conception spatiale les sept
astronautes ont réussi à donner
naissance à des bébés grenouille en un
temps record samedi opération ovulation
cas de grenouilles admise à bord
reçoivent une injection d'hormones
dimanche fécondation de centaines de
l'heureux événement spatiale était
attendu au plus tard pour aujourd'hui
mais c'est cette nuit que deux
charmantes et a rompu le ciel
satisfaction de l'équipe pour la
première fois conception et naissance
ont pu se dérouler en apesanteur
c'est la fête à bord meury le japonais
s'adonne à son exercice favori démontrer
l'application à l'espace de la loi de
newton sur la gravitation le sont
comprises est imité par l'une des
grenouilles génitrice sous l'oeil de
l'astronaute mark lee qui veut tester la
capacité d'orientation des batraciens en
apesanteur
deux cars pas tant de leur tour pour des
tests similaires mais il ya un problème
dans l'aquarium et la nasa reste muette
comme une carpe
on va d'autres images étonnantes la
première visite dans une grotte oublier
une forme de vie inconnue jusqu'à
présent il est développé un mille-pattes
carnassiers ans corpulent suivi ces
organismes vivent est ici depuis trois
millions d'années dans une caverne
roumaine que nous conte fable de france
2 ont pu visiter et vous pouvez voir ces
images beaucoup plus longuement dans
leur journal de 20 heures c'est à dire
donc quelques minutes à la fin de ce 19
20 le prochain rendez vous avec la
rédaction c'est soir 3 présenté par
catherine matausch portera ce soir à 22h
cas et avant cela sur france 3 une
soirée cinéma
une soirée spéciale alain delon dans
quelques secondes la météo complète de
florence klein à demain 19h bonsoir
bonsoir
où